est ce que tu crois que tu as
fascination pour les couples royaux
vient dé du monde et rami c'est l'idée
de quelque chose qui finit pas mais de
son attirance pour la monarchie
c'est ton côté midinette surtout je ne
crois pas non plus à côté au début ça a
commencé dans un peu comme une
provocation
parce que j'en avais marre d'être
comme ça catalogué le neveu tout ça et
puis et puis je me suis vraiment
intéressé et je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait pas que des imbéciles ou
des des névrosés qui s'y intéresser
alors ça m'a un peu rassurée mais au
plan politique est-ce que tu serais
d'accord pour qu'on fasse un référendum
en france pour demander aux gens non
silva la monarchie ne seraient pas
d'accord parce qu'on voit pas ce que
parce que les gens n'ont pas besoin
parce que ces gens n'ont plus besoin ils
ont une
en france c'est des institutions de
gaulle a fait des institutions très bon
manger être parfaite parce qu'elle
réconcilie on va pas faire un cours un
devoir constitutionnel mais elle
réconcilie toutes les tendances
françaises ont elles sont les
institutions de la monarchie c'est un
fois élu pour sept ans + 7 ans ça fait
14 ans c'est le temps d'un règne
interminable
c'est bonapartiste parce qu'il parle
directement au peuple
et puis c'est la république parce que
parce que c'est un président la
république c'est des institutions idéal
d'ailleurs lui vous l'aurez voulu avoir
une monarchie mais puis finalement il
s'est dit que c'était pas possible il ya
pas jouer où il ya pensé semble-t-il on
dit un peu trop qu'il ya pensé à mon
avis n'y a pas pensé énormément des
lettres quand même
il ya pensé dis moi c'est quand même pas
étrange que le neveu du présent a ajouté
que son organisme
ben non parce que toute façon si c'était
une monarchie seraient près du trône
alaouite